[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back
to chess openings explained tonight we
are going to continue
our discussion on the f3 nimzo as i
cover
more and more and more lines uh i'm
reminded
of just how deep this opening is and
just how much there is to discover and
how much there is
to know so tonight we are going to
continue talking
about what happens when black castles on
move four
uh in the previous lecture we discussed
a pretty surprising
night jump out to h5 and tonight we are
going to discuss
an even more surprising night jump back
to the
to the eighth rank knight e8 so to
understand what that's all about i want
to start with the game
between sergey volkov and artur's nike
sons and now you may know
the name artur's nike sons from his
blossoming twitch career i believe he
has started
but in this game he was on the
unfortunate end of the game against
sergey volkov f3 nimzo
master so let's see what happened here
we started with d4
knight f6 c4 e6 knight c3
bishop b4 entering the nimso indian f3
entering the f3 nemzo indian um
and then black castles again this is
what we're discussing a3
takes takes and then this is the the
first real decision point
for black now in the previous lecture we
discussed
how black can try and prevent the move
of e4
by white with the idea of knight out to
h5
and the point was now of course if e4
there's queen h4
and after knight h3 black's idea was to
go f5
and control e4 and so while knight h5
was perhaps a little bit surprising to a
lot of people myself included
it did have the very clear idea of
defending
the e4 square now this move that we're
going to talk about tonight
is on the same turn rather than advance
the night out to h5
black can occasionally retreat the
knight to e8s and at first glance this
looks absolutely
ridiculous white is going to take over
the center
with the move e4 and all of black's
pieces are back on
the starting rank all black has managed
to do
is trade off the only piece that got off
the back rank
and move the other piece back to it so
what is the point well to understand the
move like 98 i wanted to start with a
game where 98
wasn't played and maybe that'll help us
understand why this move
is sort of necessary by black so in this
game
nyx lens actually just starts with the
more natural c5
why is this slightly more natural well
black's idea
is to number one challenge the d4 square
a little bit
and number two go for a big attack
on the c4 pawn using these queen side
pieces
this is black's main idea in the knight
e8 line
going b6 knight c6 net a5
and bishop a6 to apply pressure here so
c5 is essentially an attempt to improve
it you know why waste time on 98
when we can get going with this stuff
right away challenge the dark squares in
the center
then play this knight out to a5 and call
it a day
you know show white what's going on so
first white should just continue
naturally with the move e4 there's no
reason not to
then we're going to look at the move d6
guarding
this c pawn notably if black
were to start with the move knight c6
then perhaps the move e5
would be strong by white highlighting
the fact
that this pawn has not yet moved out to
d6
so d6 first is a bit more accurate now
we get bishop d3
and now knight c6 and so far so good for
black right everything's going according
to plan
maybe it is going to turn out to be true
that 98 was a waste of time
well now white continues with knight e2
and black continues with the plan
with b6 but now perhaps
the point of 98 is going to become clear
after white's next move
it turns out rather surprisingly that
bishop g5
i think is an excellent move here for
white
that is going to force some positional
concessions
by black in black's perfect world white
would have just continued with something
like bishop e3
black would have time to go bishop a6
let's say white castles
and then knight a5 and black white is
simply losing a pawn on
c4 nothing really to be done here about
it and it's going to be black who's
better
but with this move bishop g5 white is
actually making
some very very serious threats very very
quickly very rapidly so for example now
if
black were to continue with something
like bishop a6
does anybody in the chat know what white
would do
to continue white to move here and
essentially win the game
wait to move and essentially win the
game
what do you guys have for me
so jonas has the right idea white would
love to play e5
but slightly wrong execution if you play
e5 here black is simply
going to take it two times and then
your center is gone so the best move for
white
is actually the move f4 and this creates
the threat of e5
and it turns out this threat is quite
simply impossible to stop
if you play h6 white will simply retreat
the bishop if you take on d4
i will simply take back and e5
is going to come e5 by black
doesn't really help white is going to
castle
and now even if i'm not playing pawn to
e5
my pressure down the f file is going to
decide the game
um for example let's i don't know it's
hard to suggest a move let's say rookie
8
i'm going to take e5 and take f6 and
this
is just totally busted for black
your castle is broken so
f4 is the threat and it would in fact
just be winning after a nonchalant move
like bishop a6 but of course nyxons is a
strong grandmaster and plays the move e5
and so seemingly this threat of bishop
g5 has
very you know summarily been dealt with
what was the point
of drawing this pawn out to e5 well
we'll see
that volkov actually sort of tailors his
play
around the fact that black has been
forced to make these slight concessions
in the center
put this pawn onto e5 and give white
some targets to go after
so nixon's now continues sorry volkov
continues with
d5 the pressure on d4
was mounting uh knight a5 by black now
and we see our first remaneuvering of
knight to g3 it's important to play this
move
before castling because now we can
respond to bishop a6
with queenie queen to e2 and for the
moment
we are going to be holding on to our c4
pawn
uh this particular game continued with
h6
bishop back to e3 rookie eights
and then sergey volkov makes a few
inaccuracies here
he plays the move a4 which is seemingly
a natural move but i just don't think
it's
totally relevant here but we will stick
with the game a4 played
uh it doesn't really give away too much
at all black is not better by any
stretch and i think white has a small
small pole still just not the most
useful move perhaps a bit better would
be the simple
king's side castles queen e2 queen c2
any of these moves but a4 is perfectly
fine
the game continues with knight d7 and
now white continues
with h4 so the plans are beginning to
become
a little bit more clear this is the sort
of position
that white is aiming for when you get
this blocked off center
white has very mobile king side pawns
and
sergey volkov is going to look to attack
the black king on the king's side
in the meantime the thing to look at for
black
is where is the activity on the queen
side and
thanks to these slight concessions that
were that were forced because the bishop
came out to g5
uh those concessions being putting the
pawn on d6 putting the pawn on e5
and putting the pawn on h6 well now
black has no way
to open up the c file to get at this
pawn no way to challenge the c
pawn with d5 no way to open the e file
to place a knight on e5 all of these
moves are not available to black
and for those reasons black is sort of
without counter play on the queen's side
and is going to have to spend the rest
of the game defending on the king side
and we'll see
that that is no easy task so
all in all it's easy to say black plays
98 because of bishop g5
but the real details are a lot trickier
and are very important to understand
so why does white why does black play 98
yes
it's because of bishop g5 but more
specifically it's because of these
concessions
that bishop g5 is going to force black
is going to need
to concede some things in order to get
that bishop off of g5
and it turns out it's simply better for
black just to not allow bishop g5 in the
first place
by playing this awkward looking move
knight e8
with all that talking though let's see
it in action how did volkov continue
this game
well nike sons plays the move knight to
f8
trying to defend the king's side a
little bit more
as i said it's going to be tough to find
any counter play on the queen side you
can play bishop a6 but queen a2 is
simple enough to deal with threat
the game continues now with the funny
looking king f2 just
developing the king notably this rook is
well placed on the h file and f2 is a
safe square for the king
knight g6 was the continuation and then
volkov plays a very excellent move in
the form of knight h5
volkov does not care about losing the
h-pawn
in order to open up this rook's access
to the king's side
and with knight h5 he's making the very
serious threat
of playing g4 on the next turn following
that up with g5
exploding the king's side and thirdly
this move is also stopping the idea of
knight f4 not h5
sort of the perfect move here for white
and it's going to give white some
advantage
the game continued with knight takes h4
now g3
4 says this knight back away knight g6
and now white to move again chat what is
the move
to seize the winning advantage here for
white
yes as always this is of course
ben feingold's least favorite opening
but we do what we can
without his support as well we do what
we can
um so the idea is actually a little bit
surprising
if you've been listening to everything
i've been saying so far
you know i mentioned that this e5 move
is a little bit of a concession
in part because black is unable to get
pressure down the e file
and unable to occupy this square with
the pieces
so it might not be your first instinct
to play the move f4
and grant black this sort of counter
play but in this case this
is the correct move white is going to
open the g file and
deliver checkmate shortly uh by the way
you guys did have a good idea with
knight takes g7 didn't want to discount
this
this move wins as well but a wise man
once told me
you know sometimes it's it's better to
win with all your pieces on the board
than to win with uh with a knight
missing you know
why is that well if you make a few
inaccuracies you might find yourself
down a piece
whereas here you are not going to find
yourself down a piece
and if you make a few inaccuracies
probably your position is still going to
be okay
so when in doubt don't sacrifice pieces
if your position is already good
that's just good practical chess no need
to take unnecessary risks the game
continued though with e takes f4
g takes f4 now queen e7
applying pressure down the e file and
then
things went a little bit crazy with
queen e2
knight c4 bishop c4 and queen takes e4
black
sacrificing a piece to get back into the
game but now white is up a piece and
should go on
to win the game we are well out of the
scope of opening theory here
so i'm gonna leave it at that there was
a little bit more back and forth left
in the game but whites up a piece should
be good enough
for a victory so let's recap what
happened in this game
let's recap what happened uh black chose
instead
of the normal knight e8 to continue with
the immediate c5
and to understand why this is less
popular why this is
maybe not quite as good we saw e4 by
white
d6 by black bishop d3 knight c6
knight e2 and then after black begins
this plan
of going knight knight a5 and bishop a6
we see white develop out with bishop g5
and start forcing
these concessions uh by black
and we are going to return to this one
more time at the end of the lecture if
we have time
because perhaps a better try than the
move e5 which has been played
twice is the move h6 which has been
played
zero times so that's just some home
cooking i have for you guys there
about this move h6 because i do think it
could potentially be an interesting try
for black that being said though
i don't want to waste all you guys time
analyzing something that's ever been
played
so we are going to return to the most
common move
which is knight e8s with our first main
game
of the night between uh someone
by the name of gunter haika
and someone by the name of vilmars
korzens
very famous chess players uh they are
not super gm's by any means
but the line i'm going to be
recommending is actually a little bit
more of an
off beat line so i'm going to get into
what that is exactly but first i'm just
going to show
sort of an example of how the main line
theory goes and why i'm actually not
recommending that
for white so we are going to start with
the main line stuff
of course all f3 nimzo stuff castles a3
we're looking at takes takes and 98
still going e4 here it's the only move
that makes sense
and now black's idea as stated is very
very simple black is
going to pile up on this pawn we see
bishop d3
bishop a6 knight c6 is also a perfectly
playable move it doesn't really change
anything for us
so bishop a6 and now the move i am
recommending
is the slightly strange looking move a4
and i do think this is a great way for
white to apply some pressure to black's
position
now the mainline move here is a little
bit more natural it is continued with
the
natural move knight h3 so i just want to
take a quick look at this
and talk a little bit about why i'm not
going to recommend this line
so the play is pretty linear here most
of the games go the same way black has
this one little plan
and is going to do it we see castles
now knight a5 queen e2 and
once again the difference between this
98 line
and the line with the knight on f6
starts to become clear
when black plays the move c5 now
d5 would be a natural move for white to
try to play
but it's simply not going to be very
good here for one
black is able to capture on d5 versus
the other line with the pawn on
e5 and for two black can sort of just
leave this pawn here
even occasionally play the move knight
d6 and the pressure on c4 is in fact
mounting whereas in that first game that
we saw black's play
on the queen side sort of faded away and
we never really saw
you know anything concrete happen
against these pawns
so i just wanted to mention that the
main move for white is not d5 for those
reasons the main move is e5
trying to deliver checkmate turns out
bishop takes h7
is a real threat so black should respond
with the move f6
and there are a couple options here
including rook a2 to c2 which i talked
about at the end of the last lecture
and the more analysis that i did on it
the the less i sort of liked it
but the idea is the same as in bishop f4
you just get your pieces out but black
is succeeding
in pressuring uh this pawn on c4
and here black will just continue with
the move d5
and after a quick pawn sacrifice
white is not really going to be able to
keep this pawn with
pressure on d4 and c4 mounting
and i found no possible way to break
through with an advantage
for white in these cases notably
black is also able to first play rook
c8s rook ac1 and and follow this up with
d5 as well
and the lines stay stay largely the same
and they stay perfectly fine
for black the further you dig into these
lines the
less problems black actually has and if
you're not careful
white may actually end up on the worst
end of some end games
with this weak d4 pawn for example let's
say something like this
take here take here
take on d3 take on d3 queen takes d5
and it's actually going to be white
facing some pressure
on this structure white still has some
threats on the king's side and black
definitely still has problems to solve
but honestly i prefer the black side of
these positions this is actually my
preferred line against the f3 nimso
whenever i
end up on the black side of it and for
good reason i think black doesn't really
have any major issues here and if white
isn't careful white's going to end up on
the worst end of things
so what am i recommending instead
well i'm recommending sort of a more
measured approach
by white rather than going all out
over extending our pawns out to e5 early
on
i'm recommending this move a4 in part
because it grants
white some flexibility and partly
because it introduces
some very concrete threats that black
will have to solve
at the risk of being worse if black
doesn't really play correctly here
black is going to be under quite a great
deal of pressure
so what is the idea of a4 other than to
play some sort of random waiting move
well the point is of course bishop a3
when due to the awkward placement of
black's pieces this rook is actually
borderline
trapped and we'll see that in our main
line here this rook may
end up getting captured so how should
black respond well this position has
actually been reached
only 14 times in the leashes database on
move 14
and black has played knight c6 11 times
so that's what we're going to start with
here i think this is
you know it's fair to say that this is
the main
variation now white should continue
as planned with bishop a3 forcing this
pawn out
to the d6 square and from here the move
f4 is going to be the natural
continuation so sort of similar to what
we saw in the bishop g5 line
except in this case our bishop is
planted on
a3 and we're not really threatening e5
f4 is more of just a move to take some
extra space
and grant this knight the f3 square
let's see how play might continue
knight a5 is the most natural now queen
e2
defends the c4 pawn and we're going to
look at this move
c5 this is of course the natural
continuation
of black's play this is the main plan
for black in these positions and there's
no reason why
black should deviate from that here
white is going to continue with knight
f3 that's part of the reason why we
played the move f4
and from here you can very much expect
black to continue with rook c8
this is as stated sort of the main idea
for black
now we're going to look at the move e5
for
white i think this is the way to go
in this case and what is going on
in this position well it's very similar
to what we just looked at in the main
line
with a few key differences namely
if black starts trying to liquidate
things
as we saw in the previous line it's not
going to be white who ends up with a
random d4
weakness it's going to be black who ends
up with weak
a3 to f8 diagonal and black is going to
have to sacrifice in exchange
if they decide they want to open things
up like this
so i want to start with what happens if
black does
in fact sacrifice that exchange then
we're going to take a look at a slightly
different game
to show what happens if black sort of
chickens out and says no
i don't want to sacrifice this rook
that's a little bit too scary
and what chances white has there so
black is going to start with the move g6
most likely
this has been played five of the six
times we've seen this position
uh apparently the move h6 has also been
played but this sort of looks like some
nonsense to me
i don't really understand this move i
think it's just a bad move white should
continue with castles
but g6 is what we're focusing on
and here white simply castles king's
side and
now in the game uh vilmars corzins one
way or the other decided
that this rook had to go so i keep
saying that black is going to have to
sacrifice this piece but i haven't said
how
so let's take a look the most natural
move is c takes d4
for black that was the point of rook c8
that was the point of all these moves
indirectly that was sort of the point of
knight to e8
pressuring this d4 pawn to open up the c
file that is black's plan
so of course black should be inclined to
go for it
white's going to play c takes d4 back of
course
and now after bishop takes c4 white can
actually apply some
pressure with the move not bishop takes
c4
drawing this knight into the game but
with rook a
to c1 and what's going on here
well white is of course applying
pressure down this c
file and if this bishop moves out of the
way you can expect e takes d6 to come
with a lot of problems for black to
solve and that's exactly what happens in
this game
black chooses bishop d5 we see rook
takes c8
queen takes c8 e takes d6 and
now all of a sudden it's very unclear
how black is going to be able to save
this rook
and in fact this turns out to just be an
impossible
task if you try knight f6 for example
then
d7 can still come among other moves
maybe rook c1 first is even better
but at the very least there's d7 and
bishop takes f8
and if queen to d8 as played in the game
again this move d7
now this is the best that white can do
black is going to take the pawn
uh and white throws in a nice little
inner meso you can also just take the
rook immediately
but this center meso protects our a4
pawn for the moment
and now we see that simplifications do
happen
knight c7 bishop f8 king takes f8
and here white is going to be slightly
better
is it enough for a full point likely
against good play it is not going to be
enough for a full point
uh i think black should have very very
good chances to draw this end game
but you know an exchange is an exchange
and i think practically
if you end up in this position in an
over the board chess game
i know i myself would be quite happy
with what i got out of the opening
this is the type of position where white
is going to be able to play
a ton of moves and black is sort of just
going to have to
try and find some sort of defensive
setup and just sit back
and let it happen so this
i think is the best that black can do
if black is gonna go for this sort of
normal plan right if black is continuing
on you know as if it were the status quo
this is the type of thing black is is
going to be able to expect
the game itself continued with the
immediate queen d1 which is not my
favorite move i think trading the queens
is actually going to be favorable for
black
but the game ended in a draw pretty
peacefully with white being unable to
shake loose
these powerful knights and get at this a
pawn effectively
a few more moves were played and at the
end of the day
the a pawns were traded the knight was
traded
for the bishop and a draw was
agreed after rook d7
so that is sort of the crux of our
opening line here i am recommending this
move 12
a4 is it 12 i guessed wrong it's not 12.
9 a4 way back on move 9 and i'm
recommending this move
in in attempts to make black's main plan
less attractive that's what i love doing
against really any opening line i love
taking the plan
that my opponent sort of has prepared
that they're knowledgeable about
and playing the move that makes that
plan the hardest now the main line of
this opening
unfortunately i think the main plan for
black is good enough
and against a4 that main plan might be
good enough for a half point
but it's going to take a lot of work
from black
so of course this was just only one of
the options for
the game to continue and i want to take
a look at some of the other
uh questions that i brought up and to do
so we're going to take a look at a
slightly higher level game
between someone named uh miso
cibalo or sabalo maybe and errold
dervishy so yeah let's just
jump into it no time to waste here we've
got a lot to cover
the game goes d4 knight f6 and
i won't waste your time seeing all the
moves we've seen this all before
again we are looking at knight e8's
again
white's reply is e4 what else
now b6 is still going to be black's idea
we have bishop d3 bishop
a6 again we are going to go with a4
knight c6 still really the only idea for
black
we have our sorry not the only idea c5
is an idea that we're going to talk
about next
but knight c6 definitely the main idea
bishop a3 is our response highlighting
this rook is awkward
drawing this pawn out to d6 and now
again
we go f4 forcing play continues with
knight a5
queen e2 c5 again this is the main plan
by black we go knight f3 rook c8
and our move again is e5 and this is the
exact same position
from the first game so why am i showing
this to you again because i want to show
you
a different middle game continuation so
here
you know i'm of course playing a little
bit of a guessing game but i suspect
black was looking at a lot of these
lines uh well again we have g6 to guard
the f5 square
uh and i guess i should mention that if
black just plays
something uh sort of nonchalant like c
takes
uh d4 uh white to move and win
in this position is is actually a good
question
so why not something like c takes d4
let's start with this before i keep
talking
let's start with this what do you think
chat
and yeah it is going to be a great gift
position bishop takes h7
is just very very strong king h7 knight
g5
and after queen h5 black's only move is
to sacrifice the queen
which of course is going to be very good
for
white so not c takes d4 but g6 instead
now we see castles and this is where in
the previous game
we saw the players opt to simplify
things with c takes d4
and black ended up sacrificing this
exchange
on f8 right now in this case
divishy perhaps uh saw these
complications and
wasn't so happy with the resulting end
game and as someone in in the chat said
it is two pieces for the exchange in
that end game
but it is very much worth noting that
black is left with two knights
which are sort of notoriously difficult
to work with in endgames
they don't work well together and
black's extra pawns
are not passed they are not advanced in
fact they are slightly
weak and can quickly become targets so
definitely white for choice in that end
game although i do suspect it is just
a draw um but anyways i think black
saw this end game coming and said no
thank you i'll have none of that
and shows the natural move knight to g7
so let's take a look at what happens if
black decides to leave the pieces on the
board
isn't so happy with this exchange
sacrifice
which is very difficult to avoid if you
do start removing the c
pawn from this diagonal so knight g7
what's the idea
well partially it is hinting at
controlling the f5 square
partially it's just clearing out a
square for this rook so that black is
not going to have to be losing in
exchange in the ensuing complications
well what should white do about this how
should we continue
our idea is not actually going to be
going
for some sort of crazy king side attack
that is just not
going to be on the cards at this point
partially because we committed our
bishop to the queen's side of the board
partially because we just have too many
weaknesses to worry about
to sort of abandon them and go off king
hunting
but what we can do is strengthen our
position further with the move rook f to
d1 and i think this is just a perfectly
good
solid move by white
now how is the game going to continue
well there are a few different
approaches that black can take
and there's unfortunately very few games
to sort of
take the example of um in this game
we're gonna see black captures on e5 now
why would black
capture on e5
well the idea is simply to grant black
target
uh grant black access to this target on
d4 and notably if white thinks
you know they're being very clever and
opening up the d file
in front of the queen i don't think this
is actually going to be
the best continuation here for white
why is that well it's going to be white
that's left with the weakness and it's
going to be rather
difficult in fact to make use of this d6
square for example plane might continue
queen c7
knight g5 rick fd8 and if you try
something like
knight e4 even the move knight e8 here
and it may look like it's black who's on
the back foot
but black's pieces all have purpose and
white's pieces especially this bishop is
now looking a little bit silly
on a3 so what should white do well
white should take back on e5 with the
pawn and keep up this pressure on this
diagonal
but for the moment i do sort of want to
discuss what happens
if black plays a few moves we've already
sort of
come to expect from the position so
first of all
if c takes d4 all the same problems are
going to be in effect here and in fact
they are only heightened
by the fact that this pawn is hanging
pretty much immediately i think white
can in fact just capture on d6 so what
about
d5 well this is a move that we've seen
before
in the main line of this 98 variation
and this is often a great way
for black to sort of break through on
this c file it adds that last little
attacker to the c4 pawn before things
start to crumble
but in this case thanks in part to our
last move rook f to d1
we are well prepared to meet this break
with c takes d5
black has to trade these bishops and now
after queen takes d5
well what's the difference in the main
line we saw that black was able to take
on d4 and sort of give us this d4
weakness that was going to be difficult
to get away
to give away but in this case white is
well prepared to meet queen takes d5
thanks to the stroke on d1 with the move
d take
c5 and this is i think really the
purpose behind this move
rook f to d1 we want to be able to give
away
this d4 weakness at a moment's notice
and
it turns out here white is simply
significantly better
with control over this d file or if
black wants to keep the d
file then white will just go up on with
c
takes b6 for example queen d3 rook d3
b takes c5 is going to allow us
a little bit of pressure here notably
this is a huge different than the
positions where there was a pawn on b6
now our bishop is a useful piece
attacking a weakness
rather than a dead bishop looking at a
protected pawn
and here what is white is just going to
be much better so again
the main point of the opening is to play
against black's natural plans and if
black is going to stay in the game
black is going to continue is going to
have to continue
to play slightly unnatural moves such as
moves like queen c7 queen e7 just
keeping the tension
perhaps this is black's best try but
still white is going to have a path
through in this case
we are going to be the ones to open
things up with
something like e takes d6 and d takes c5
now opening the d file is useful because
we have
some tactics with bishop takes g6 the
game is by no means over
there's queen takes f4 and things would
continue from here
in uh some rather complex tactics at the
very least
we can come back with bishop d3
and here there's moves like queen e5 95
um i don't want to get too bogged down
in these
specifics but the point i'm trying to
make is that black
is sort of in a tough spot if
black didn't immediately open things up
and go for that
exchange down end game why is black in a
tough spot well
because thanks to our setup white is
just well prepared for any way that
black can open the position
be it with d5 be it with c takes d4
and if black chooses not to open the
position with some
nothing moves some queen e7 queen c7
then white is ready to open up things
with e takes d6
and d takes c5 so black is really sort
of left with no good options
aside from perhaps d takes e5 which
we're going to look at
now once again the correct response is f
takes e5
keeping the pressure up on this diagonal
on the c5 pawn this is the point of our
a4
opening line now the game continued with
queen
c7 understandably removing the queen
from the d
file and now white breaks through with
one
last accurate move and that move is d5 i
think this is a great move by white
and it's a move that solidifies a
distinct advantage
for miso saballo
now obviously the game did end in a draw
as you can see on your screens
but white does have a very pleasant edge
in this position the game itself
continued with bishop b7
and then here i think white is already
making some inaccuracies with the move
queen e3 much much better
would have been d6 when after something
like bishop f3
queen f3 queen d7 it's very very clear
that white is on the better side of
things especially after the move g4
this knight is sort of locked out of the
game it can come back to c6
uh but this knight especially has
nowhere
to go it's sort of trapped in this
prison between g7
and e8 for the and for all of you know
eternity until the end until the end of
time
uh and this once again is going to be a
very pleasant position for
white so
that's real that's where we will leave
it for this idea
namely because in the game white played
a very bad move queen e3
and then black is just able to pretty
simply take this pawn
for free and that is in fact the end of
white's advantage so questions
on this line because i feel like it's
very very
relevant to understand what's happening
here
after castles uh in the spot that black
finds himself in
right you have this situation where the
natural moves don't really seem to be
working
but then if you don't play the natural
moves black is going to be left without
a plan
and white is going to be able to open
things up favorably after this move
rook f to d1 or rook a to d1 is is also
quite good
in these positions questions here
the chat is just saying thanks for doing
all their prep work for them
you're welcome uh i spent sort of all
day on this lecture
yeah if you guys like these these more
in-depth opening lectures please let me
know because
boy oh boy do they take me a long long
time
boy oh boy do they take me a long long
time
okay so no
questions on this position in particular
uh peter peterson is saying white often
avoids the nimzo with knight f3
black then prefers to transfer into a
qgd
why is that and i will very briefly
actually answer that question
because while it is not sort of specific
to our f3 nimzo it is worth
understanding
sort of some of these mechanics that
don't often get talked about with the
first three moves
by white so
uh we are going to leave this here and
then take a look at
one more sort of situation in this um
knight c6 thing i i think and
first and foremost though let's talk a
little bit about the nimzo indian
in general sort of a weird point to fit
this in i know
but it is worth mentioning that
oftentimes you'll see black play this
move order and then after knight f3
transpose into you know the normal qgd
because white did not allow the nimzo so
why don't all white players play like
this
well by playing this move three knight
c3 it's true that you allow the nimzo
indian
but i like allowing the nimzo indian
because the f3 nimzo is so
strong and it turns out there is
actually a tangible benefit to playing
knight c3
rather than knight f3 in that it allows
white to play the exchange
qgd which i do myself and this is
sort of seen as a pretty good option for
white against the qgd
and this is sort of the the mechanics at
play here so why knight c3 over knight
f3
well it gives you better options against
the qgd and why to qgd
why do players transpose into the qgd
after knight f3
well because white is missing this
important c takes d5 option so important
to note there
but let us move on now to our next game
between
uh rajul vant ketel
getting some real known names on the
show today why is that well again it's
because i'm recommending
some pretty uncommon lines but these
games are still instructive
nonetheless so once again we have a lot
to cover so let's just do it
d4 knight f6 c4 and again
i've come to realize that it is a waste
of everyone's time
and my mental energy to say all these
things out loud i will though
say the relevant details after 98 again
we take over the center with e4
b6 again black's idea is bishop a6
we develop bishop a6 comes and now we
play this
you know surprise move of a for
activating this bishop
along this diagonal the play continues
in this game with knight c6
one more time we see bishop a3 d6
f4 all the moves we've seen before
knight a5
queen e2 c5 knight f3 rook c8
e5 g6 and castles
right so now we've seen what happens on
knight g7
when black tries to play a bit more
slowly trying to prepare
things uh it turns out still black
cannot open up the position favorably
and then it is actually white who open
the opens up
opens the position favorably with e
takes d6 and d takes c5
now let's take one more look at the main
plan of c takes d4
because these lines are worth taking a
second look at i think if you play this
over the board in long time control
chess
after some deep thought your opponent
might decide it is
going to be necessary to go for this
main plan because the more you look at
moves like knight g7 the more you start
to realize
black's position is sort of just
meaningless there's there's no plan
there's nothing to do
and it's quite uh difficult to play so c
takes d4 we'll take another look at
c takes d4 and then just to refresh
everyone's memory the first game we
looked at
also goes with bishop take c4 and we
play this move
rook a to c one now there's a question
in chat i believe about knight b3 of
course this is just not a good move
we'll take the bishop
but once again it's worth reiterating
what happened in that first game
we saw bishop d5 and this is sort of the
only option
for black i didn't say it was the only
option in that first game
but we're gonna figure out why it's the
only option here so why is bishop d5 the
only option well after bishop d5
we've seen that it does in fact lose an
exchange by force
to this d7 idea of course i didn't
mention this either
if queen d7 knight e5 or bishop b5 both
of these moves are very very strong
and d7 anyways right and now in fact
we might just be making a queen so
we saw queen d8 in that game and that's
when we got d7
black uh lost this rook on f8 but got an
end game
that is likely going to be drawn now in
this case we're gonna see what happens
if black goes for this natural plan and
then chickens out and plays the move
bishop takes d3 this is sort of the
reasonable alternative that you might
expect so what's happening
after bishop takes d3 well of course
white is going to take back
now to avoid this line of rook takes c8
with e takes d6
black captures on c1 we are going to
take back
and then in the game black plays this
move queen d7
and at first glance this sort of seems
like everything black could hope for
right you
got to play your main plan you got to
simplify things a little bit
and you didn't even have to lose your
rook on f8
in exchange now uh
of course once you look past those
surface level things
you start to realize that black is
unable to move
any pieces right you know we just saw
this queen go from d8 to d7 which is
great it's making a threat but you look
at this knight
this knight moves the d6 pawn falls you
look at this rook
and it has zero legal moves obviously
the king's going nowhere
and this knight is starting to look a
little bit short on squares right even
if it comes back to b7
it's not as if it has a future on c5 or
d6
and on c6 it's going to be a little bit
loose
right and with these three pieces sort
of strewn across the board
i do think white is going to have a
pretty pleasant advantage
in this case especially with the
pressure on d6
and i should say this is often just the
downside of this knight e8 variation
in many many lines black is going to
find himself
with a very tough time actually
activating this piece right once you
play 98
it's difficult to get it back into the
game especially after a pawn lands
on e5 as we see here so
nothing too crazy going on in this
position it's just exactly what it seems
uh white has sacrificed a pawn on c4
but black can't move any of their pieces
and is going to have a very very
difficult time
getting anything back into the game the
game continued with the move
queen b5 by the way which is a great
start defends the pawn on a4
black cannot really even consider taking
on b5 here
for example knight b7 rook c8
and black is is pretty close to losing
knight g7
rook c7 knight g5 for example
and all pieces hanging for black
definitely not what you want to be doing
so rather than queen b5
black tried queen back to d8 in the game
perhaps
showing once and for all that this
position is in fact
pretty desperate um now though it's
actually tough to figure out how to
break through with
white and that's the problem that that
white actually ran into in the game
and in the actual game white let the
advantage
slip away and black managed to actually
come out on top with a victory which is
pretty impressive from this position
so how should white have continued well
i think
rather than queen b5 the move queen c2
was actually a better idea now it's not
too late to go for it
for example after queen d3
black's best idea is to simply repeat
the position with queen d7
and now after queen c2 the idea
starts to become a little bit clear
white is just going to invade
on the c file and in doing so
we'll uh go after the queen side pawns
on a7 and b6
and also come after this d pawn on d6
as well these are sort of the targets
that white is going after
and it is more than more than enough to
make up for the the one pawn in
compensation white is also thinking
about playing the move bishop b4 by the
way
you know temporarily misplacing this
knight as well adding yet another target
on this queen's side now uh
how is the game actually going to
continue well just for example let's say
a6 aiming for b5 to eliminate one of
these weaknesses
bishop b4 for example knight back to b7
queen c6 and if trades
white is already simply winning winning
the chess game here
um black is not really able to put too
much put up too much of a fight and i
think practically
this position is always going to be
easier to play with
white so questions on
this last line that we're going to look
at
in this particular a4 knight c6
variation uh and once we get through the
questions
i am going to talk about this move c5
which has only been seen three times but
i think is very very important
and is in fact black's best move we've
seen that after knight c6
black actually comes under a little bit
of pressure and honestly that the best
i'm finding for black are these slightly
uncomfortable positions where white does
have some pull or of course that
exchange down
end game which is not the most
comfortable
end game of all time so questions here
yeah and i agree with what the chatroom
is saying which is why i'm recommending
these lines um
against this main move knight c6 which
is by far the most popular
i think white is is getting you know the
more aggressive game
which is in general i think a good thing
and is getting objectively good
positions now are they winning positions
probably not that's a lot to ask out of
your opening to be winning all the time
uh but now let us move on to this move
of
c five and why this move is a little bit
better than knight c6 so let's talk
about it
in yet another game this time between
two players by the names of shrom
and pro cop again two nobodies but they
played a pretty good chess game so let's
take a look at it here
we have all the same opening moves
uh once again knight e8 once again e4
b6 bishop d3 bishop a6
a4 is our big idea and now we see the
introduction
of our move c5
and this is a move i actually struggled
against a little bit
to find a good line for white i had
already spent a lot of time on these
knight c6 variations
and they were all looking pretty pretty
reasonable for white pretty decent as
you guys were seeing
but then this move c5 sort of hit me
like a truck and i had to work very hard
to find a line
that could put any pressure on black at
all so what is the point well the point
of c5
is that black is anticipating our idea
of bishop a3
and now can back this up with knight c6
what is the difference here why don't we
just continue as we have in the past
with a move like
f4 well black has one really important
idea
that black did not have previously and
it sort of changes the entire character
of the position
what idea is that well black's pawn has
not been committed
to d6 and this allows black to play the
surprising
knight d6 now in all those positions we
were looking at before
black ended up with his horrible knight
on e8 this rook on f8 was trapped
couldn't legally move
and with knight d6 black is solving a
lot of those problems
so bishop a3 simply isn't going to be
the right idea in this case notably by
the way there is
one sort of forcing variation with e5
knight c4
queen e2 but black has d5 here to sort
of save the day
and it turns out that our bishop on a3
is actually working
against us if we play e takes d6 black
is going to be able to capture this
bishop
and save the material and once again is
going to be able to free up the position
and have a pretty good game
so is all hope lost for whites well if
of course it isn't or else i wouldn't
recommend this line
i like white's position after the move
f4
with c5 black has prematurely shut down
this diagonal so there's no reason for
us to commit this bishop over to a3
when we can be doing more useful things
in the center
alright in the game we're looking at
here we have knight c6 by
black and then surprise idea number two
is going to strike it turns out
if white takes the slow approach with
something like knight f3
at the end of the day let's say queen e2
let's say rook c8 for example
and something like e5
sorry i'm going a bit wrong here d5 i
think was the line
that was giving me some consternation uh
black is able to open up the position
sort of in a way that is going to be
favorable to
black right why is that well we just
don't have this pressure down
this diagonal that we used to have right
we just don't have that anymore and i
might be misremembering the exact line
that was giving me
trouble but that is in general the
problem here
by playing c5 first by allowing
by preventing this pawn
from having to step to d6 black is able
to open up the position a lot more
favorably and a lot more quickly
compared to the previous variations so
what should we do
instead how can we solve this problem
well
we can preemptively uh open up things
sort of on
our own terms how do we do that well
it's with the surprising move
d takes c5 and here i think that white
is doing absolutely fine
do i think white is better i don't think
white is actually that much better
uh of course against perfect opening
play white should never really
be too much better but i do think white
is gonna have a good game here
and once again it's just going to be
tricky for black to enact those plans
that black is comfortable with that
they're familiar with the normal plans
in the position
they're not going to be working out here
they're not going to be comfortable and
that's the type of opening that i find
works best in a practical sense
so what happens after d takes c5 well
black sort of has a few options here
really
it comes down to two options black can
recapture the pawn
or black can leave this pawn sitting on
c5
and i want to talk about both really
quickly so let's say
knight a5 is black's choice this is
perhaps the most natural idea
for players with the black pieces in
this position whenever d takes c5
is played you generally are trying to
get white to take here as well
and then you're going to find plenty of
compensation on these open files
and i tend to agree with this assessment
which is why i think
we should now revert to our idea of
bishop a3
and that is sort of at its core the idea
of d
take c5 black is shutting down this
diagonal
but he's doing so in a manner that
allows us to rip it back
open if we so desire using this d take
c5
idea and this i think is going to turn
out to be
pretty good for for white here
once again we sort of have two options
black can take on c5 or let it sit
and if black decides it's time to take
back now white
can in fact just take this pawn and
after d6
come back with bishop b4 and after
bishop takes c4
knight f3 and i let my computer
at home think on this position for some
time
and it is close to equal but if anybody
has a pole
according to my engine it is going to be
white and that makes some intuitive
sense here
right black is left with a weakness on
d6
is left with some pressure on this
diagonal white is left with a weakness
on c3 and black has some active pieces
on the queen side
right so both players have some pluses
and minuses
but i personally believe that white's
pluses outweigh the minuses in this
position
because largely this pressure on d6
is still here and in a practical sense
we are achieving our main plan of
pressuring this diagonal and that
is more valuable than i can what i can't
stress enough how valuable that
is to be able to stick to your actual
main plan
that you're comfortable with why is that
well in a practical game
the more you play one plan the more
comfortable you become
with the nuances the more you understand
it the better moves you tend to make
and so if you can steer the game into
the sort of game
that you're comfortable with you're just
going to be playing a lot better
and that is why i think this line is so
good
for white i think most often this is
actually the type of
opposition you're going to face in this
particular variation
this plays with the black pieces i know
myself because i play this line
we tend to just go knight a5 bishop a6
against everything and in this case i do
think white is ending up
on the slightly better side of things
here
so that's d take c5 and knight a5 that i
just talked about
once again the game continues with
bishop a3 and
now i was saying if black recaptures
this pawn white is slightly slightly
better
what happens if white doesn't or black
doesn't recapture this pawn well let's
say
bishop takes on c4 now it is going to be
time to take on
b6 d6 is the only way to not lose the
rook
and then here white can go a little bit
crazier
and even take on a7 and what's going on
in this position well i didn't analyze
this one
quite as deeply because i think this is
a lot harder for a human opponent
to willingly go into with the black
pieces
why is that well white is actually going
to be the one up upon here
we're going to get all the same pressure
against d6
and it comes at the cost of one maybe
two tempe uh play might continue
something like queen c7 knight f3 queen
a7
and something like knight d4 or perhaps
queen e2 and it's again just going to be
a chess game
i don't think white is significantly
better but i definitely don't think
white is going to be on the worst side
of things here
also notably taking this pawn is not
necessarily
a requirement by white if you're not so
comfortable
going for the super crazy stuff you can
also just develop your pieces here
something like 92
but probably white should be taking this
pawn
okay so that's what happens if knight a5
there is one more idea i want to briefly
mention before getting to what
happens if black does just take this
pawn back and that
is this move e5 uh this is an idea that
hasn't cropped up in this exact position
before
but has shown up before and this is
going to change the structure ever so
slightly
so what's going on well white again
should just continue with normal
development
and now black is going to be taking back
on c5 if black doesn't
then it really is getting to the point
where white can just take on b6
so takes castles now d6 is the natural
continuation
and here i'm going to recommend the move
f5 and i just wanted to introduce this
position to
you because structures like this do
occasionally happen
when you are playing this move d take c5
so what's going on in this structure
well again black is saddled
with a weakness on d6 under slightly
different circumstances this time
and the difference now is that our
bishop is not heading to a3
but instead will likely come out to the
g5
square is white any better in this
position
again these positions are really
difficult and i honestly don't think
computers are
the best at them sort of this is the
type of position where
stockfish and uh you know magnus carlsen
might agree on
might disagree on the evaluation that's
that's all i'm trying to say
things are very very blocked and it's
more a game about slow
positional maneuvering than anything
else but
i do think i like white's chances here
in particular because this pawn on d6
is a permanent weakness in this pawn on
c4
while it is also a weakness it can
really only be attacked the two times
it's going to be difficult for black to
add another attacker there
but with all that in mind let's get to
our main game here which continued with
b
take c5 uh and i do think this makes a
lot of sense
by black in particular to lock these
pieces here and also because this idea
of bishop a3 is a little bit frightening
for black to deal with right
in combination with a4 d take c5 is
seriously
threatening to open up this diagonal
white again should continue naturally
with knight f3
and that's what happened in our main
game now knight a5
by black and here we are actually going
to deviate from the example game in the
example game
white castled king's side sacrificed
this pawn and
had to work pretty hard to get it back
so instead
let's take a look at the more natural
move which is queen e2 i like this a bit
better
just defending this pawn and now black
is again
not so easily able to add another
attacker
notably knight d6 here would be a
mistake in light of e5
when this is awkward and this
is even more awkward right we've seen
this greek gift
sacrifice before and again it is going
to be working here
so what should black do instead well
we've seen the structure after
e5 now it's time to look at the
structure after this
move f5 this is what i think
this is another really important
structure to be familiar with in this
case
and just as a short example line here
play would likely continue with
something like
e5 and now with this bishop again
threatening to come out to a3 black
should take this opportunity
to remove this bishop on c1 probably
develop out with something like
queen a5 and now i think white is on the
better side of things
one once again with the surprising move
h4 once again it's going to be
a long chess game there's going to be
there's just a lot of chess left to be
played here that is not going to be in
the realm of opening theory or opening
ideas what i can tell you about this
middle game
black is going to be looking to pressure
down the b file
and in the meantime expect to see h5h6
by white and then i think white is going
to tend to be better
in the ensuing structures why is that
well in any end game that comes up if
this pawn on
h6 is still standing on the board the
black king
is gonna have some weaknesses that it
has to account for
uh this pawn on h6 is going to be a a
very nice attacker not in the
traditional sense where white is going
to put you know things like queen g3
knight g5 and attack like this
but later on you can imagine a p sneaks
into the seventh rank
you know the d7 pawn gets moved and then
all of a sudden black is is getting
checkmated
that tends to be the benefit to having
this pawn
pushed so far up the board is it a huge
advantage definitely not
but once again i think black is going to
have to be the one
who's playing very very carefully in
this position
so that is sort of my structural
approach
to this line with um 9 c5 there are a
few really important instructure
structure
really important structures to keep in
mind number one
on knight c6 we're taking on c5
structure number one
we looked at was knight a5 and here we
are happy to open up this diagonal with
bishop a3
structure number two was what happens
after e5
and here we are just going to look to
put some pressure on the d7 pawn
soon to be d6 pawn and potentially
expand on the king side
further and lastly structure number
three arose after
b takes c5 and here
i wanted to mention this structure with
f5 e5
a lot of the plans are going to be the
same but here
white has this nice little plan of
playing h4h5h6
and putting a little thorn in black's
side
so that is going to conclude my analysis
of the surprising knight e8
variation let me know what you guys
think i think i did a pretty good job of
covering it
in depth uh keep in mind that idea i
first looked at as well
which instead of 98 was the move c5 and
remember that 98 often gets played
because this move bishop g5 by white
just provokes some
awkward weaknesses some awkward moves
like d6 e5 by black
that black really isn't so interested in
playing
we are going to continue the series next
week and next week i'm hoping to dive
ahead first into the uh difficult line
which is for c5 by black
that's where sort of the craziest games
are going to arise
and that's where a lot of fun is to be
had for
both sides um but that's gonna do it
thank you guys
so much for joining me on this edition
of chess openings explained if you're
watching live please head over to the
twitch channel for a special edition of
tactics time if you're watching the
youtube video
that is going to do it for tonight thank
you guys so much for watching
my name is caleb denby and i will see
you next time
you